six mois de prison avec sursis c'est la
peine à laquelle a été condamné
aujourd'hui un propriétaire de chien
en conclusion d'une histoire d'abandon
cruel les faits remontent à un an alors
qu'un huissier effectuer un état des
lieux pour une procédure d'expulsion
dans un appartement à nevers il tombe
dans la salle de bain sur le corps d'un
chien en décomposition un labrador de 6
ans décédé depuis près d'un mois et ne
pesant plus que 15 kg au lieu des 48
relevé sur son carnet de santé
après enquête il s'avère que son maître
a tout simplement déménagé en laissant
son animal derrière lui un abandon
doublé de maltraitance qui a indigné les
associations de protection des animaux
qui se sont portés partie civile que je
pense que la souffrance a été extrême
pour cet animal qui a essayé de s'enfuir
par tous moyens qui a bu l'eau dans les
toilettes puisque il n'avait pas d'eau
et qui agonise et au fil du temps faute
de nourriture et d'eau il s'est vu
mourir c'est indéniable
aujourd'hui nous avions des faits qui
était établi qu'ils étaient reconnus il
aurait été normal que une peine de
prison ferme comme les l'avait demandé
le procureur soit prononcée nous sommes
vraiment très surpris et une fois encore
très déçu le propriétaire du chien
absent à l'audience comparaissait pour
actes de cruauté par atteintes
volontaires à la vie d'un animal
il encourait jusqu'à deux ans de prison
mais le procureur avait requis six mois
ferme
le juge a finalement opté pour un simple
sursis assortis de dommages et intérêts
et de l'interdiction définitive de
posséder un animal